[Musique]
sur le courtage qui sépare d'un
instruite du parlement quelques
manifestants qui n'ont pas de bons mots
à l'endroit de leurs dirigeants
négative
imaginez là au centre de la controverse
des rassemblements arrosée à la
résidence du premier ministre alors
qu'on demandait aux britanniques de
respecter des mesures de confinement
loris johnson n'a pas participé à tous
ces événements mais il a passé quelques
dizaines de minutes à l'un d'entre eux
dans le jardin la résidence en mai 2020
les participants étaient invités à
apporter leur propre consommation
personne ne m'a dit que c'était contre
les règles citytld défendu mardi
ajoutant qu'il pensait participer à une
rencontre de travail
c'est lui qui nous rappelait tous les
jours quelles étaient les règles réponse
manifestants
braun qui s'est également fait sentir
dans les murs du parlement l'opposition
a bombardé le premier ministre de
questions et exigé sa démission
c'est une perte de temps et pas en boris
johnson qui demande à ses collègues
d'attendre encore un peu un rapport
d'enquêté sur les fêtes à downing street
devrait être rendue publique la semaine
prochaine si le premier ministre peut
toujours compter sur de fidèles alliés
sur les banques est conservatrice
certains sont à bout de patience le
député a décidé de faire défection pour
rejoindre les travaillistes un autre un
vétéran conservateurs ne s'est pas gêné
pour dire sa manière de penser à son
chef
ou non de dieu par tsn lancé un groupe
d'élus temps même de recueillir
suffisamment d'appuis au sein du caucus
pour forcer la tenue d'un vote de
confiance
de perdre des plumes dans les sondages
les conservateurs n'hésiteront pas à
remplacer leur chair croit cet
universitaire
sept experts comparent boris johnson un
chat qui a neuf vies
le premier ministre en a déjà perdu 8
dit il mais il rappelle que le
politicien aguerri a déjà survécu à
d'autres crises
mellick rust de hengebart
michel meurice avant est plus folle le
premier ministre a annoncé aujourd'hui
que certaines mesures sanitaires comme
le port du masque dans certains dieux et
la recommandation de travailler de la
maison allait être levée dès la semaine
prochaine une annonce importante qui n'a
toutefois pas fait nombre à la
principale discussions politiques du
royaume uni l'avenir de boris johnson si
rafa movie auclair radio canada à
londres